Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski is back home after a surprise
visit to Washington D.C he broke up the
journey by stopping in Poland where he
met with his polish counterpart on Jay
Duda an aide to Duda said the leader
spoke for about two hours posting on
social media zelenski said they
discussed the year's historic challenges
due to a full-scale war
while in Washington zelenski predicted
that next year would be a turning point
in the war but stressed that Ukraine is
still very much relying on continued
support from its Western allies
president zielinski was given the red
carpet treatment as he arrived at the
White House
greeted like an old friend by his U.S
counterpart Joe Biden
they've spoken many times on the phone
but this was the first face-to-face
meeting since Russia invaded Ukraine
in the Oval Office Biden Granite
solenski another wish high on Ukraine's
weapons list
we're going to continue to strengthen
Ukraine's ability to defend itself
particularly air defense and that's why
we're going to be providing Ukraine with
Patriot missile battery
for solenski it was an opportunity to
pay his respects to Ukraine's biggest
backer
I want to give you something
one guy he's really a real hero real
Captain
and he asked me to pass his award and he
asked me to best use of work to
President Biden
you will understand
a is the captain of heimer's battery
yes he's very brave and he said give it
to very brave president and I want to
give you that of the cross
for military
Merit that is one God loves it yes well
undeserved but much appreciated thank
you thank you thank you
for Joe Biden it was a chance to send a
clear signal to Russia that the U.S is
in it to win it
the United States is committed to
ensuring that the brave Ukrainian people
can continue continue to defend their
country against Russian aggressions as
long as it takes the president of
Ukraine
next up for salenski a Heroes welcome as
he addressed a rare joint session of the
United States Congress
Against All Odds
and doom and gloom
scenarios Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and Kicking
our two Nations
are allies in this battle
and next year will be a turning point I
know it the point when Ukrainian college
and American resolve must guarantee the
future of our common Freedom the freedom
of people who stand for their values
Vladimir solenski knows support like
this in Washington will be vital in the
months or years of fighting ahead but
it's not guaranteed
some Republicans are concerned about the
billions being given to Ukraine and when
they take control of the house next year
they might try to tighten the purse
drinks
let's go now to Russia analyst Maria
katamaze for the Russian perspective on
this Maria what reactions have we seen
from Moscow to zelenski's U.S trip
well the reaction from the Russian side
weren't as expected Kremlin a
spokesperson Dmitry peskov expressed the
disappointment since there was neither a
call for peace no Readiness to listen to
Russia's security concerns as he puts it
according to the Kremlin this means that
the U.S is indirectly fighting with
Russia essentially what Moscow does is
to reinforce once again the narrative
about total dependency of Vladimir
zelenski's decision making on the Biden
Administration and here it must be said
that in Russia it's widely believed that
that Ukraine that Washington is fueling
the conflict by providing military
equipment for Ukraine Vladimir Putin has
stated several times that she wants
peace and Military assistance to Ukraine
in his view is somewhat alienating Keith
and Moscow from peace talks
I want to ask you do you think that the
u.s's promise of more support and the
delivery of patriot missile systems is
going to further escalate the situation
well Moscow has already stated that the
Patriot defense system which will help
Ukraine to defend its airspace will be
seen as an escalation and a legitimate
Target for it for its attacks however
many analysts believe that this can be
part of so-called escalation game when
Russia is threatening Western countries
in hope that they will support Ukraine
less and we have heard this vague
threats from Kremlin since February
especially at the beginning of the war
when they made many Western leaders
alert and cautious about about military
assistance for Ukraine
Ukraine that we we see now the kremlin's
threatening narrative does not work very
well at this moment
okay now briefly uh before I let you go
we are also hearing reports that
Russia's defense minister Sergey shoigu
has visited Frontline troops again
that's two visits in less than a week
can you tell us what you think is behind
that
well firstly we don't really know if he
was actually on the front line this time
as you said already a couple of days ago
it was announced by the Russian minister
of defense that shoego visited the front
line but after some time some analysts
and journalists discovered that he was
filmed in an area in an occupied Crimea
which is not close to the front line and
well anyways he did it for for a reason
given the rising discontent over the
conditions and equipment was by many
family members of Russian soldiers this
was to show to the Russian audience that
the military commander is also with
their army and cares about his soldiers
but choi's visit can also be a message
for ukrainians we are here and we are
not willing to stop our aggression